Çeviri: Yunus ASIK
Gözden geçirme: Ece Ünalan
Şunu söyleyeceğim arkadaşlar,
öncelikle burada olmak çok heyecan verici.
Çünkü kaygıları olan, hayalleri olan
insanların huzurundayım şu anda.
Her birinizin çok seçilmiş
olduğunu düşünüyorum.
Ben buraya sadece bir kişinin
hayatına dokunmaya geldim,
bir kişi.
Eğer burada,
bu salonda bir kişinin hayatında,
iz bırakabilirsem ben hedefime
ulaşmış olacağım.
Ben bir kişinin hayatına dokunurken,
içinizden birisi de benim
hayatıma dokunabilir.
Yani, tek taraflı bir dokunuştan
bahsetmiyorum.
Belki içinizden birisi biraz sonra
benim hayatıma dokunacak,
sizin sayenizde benim hayatım değişecek.
Şimdi, tabi biraz önce
Gezegen Mehmet deyince,
Gezegen Mehmet'in doğuşunu
kısaca paylaşayım sizinle.
Radyo hayatıma nasıl girdi?
Ben şu günlerde hep şunu söylüyorum,
"Hayal kurmak, insanın kendini
keşfetmesidir."
Çılgın hayalleri kuranlar
bugün dünyayı değiştirdiler.
Ama o hayalleri kurdukları dönemlerde,
onlara deli muamelesi yapıldı.
O çılgın hayalleri kuranlar hiçbir zaman
omuzlarda taşınmadılar.
Dolayısıyla, hayalleriniz lütfen sınırsız
ve özgür olsun.
Dedemin bir radyosu var,
o zamanlar 8-9 yaşındayım,
6-7 yaşındayım belki de.
Orta dalga, kısa dalga, uzun dalga.
Radyoyu önüme koyuyorum,
evde kimse olmadığı zaman.
Benim yaş grubumda olanlar bilirler,
fm kanalı daha yok ortada.
O kanallar arasında dolaşırken
değişik sesler çıkıyor.
O seslerin, uzaylılar tarafından bana
gönderildiğini hayal ediyordum,
yani 6-7 yaşındayken.
Ben de onlara cevap veriyorum.
Biz konuşuyoruz aslında uzaylılarla,
ama ne onlar beni anlıyorlar
ne de ben onları anlıyorum.
Anlaşılmaz bir durum söz konusu.
Radyonun hayatıma giriş noktası bu.
Daha sonra, fm radyosu çıktı.
Fm radyosu var, çift hoparlörlü,
şöyle düşünün:
Köy yolundan, patika yoldan
otobana geçiş gibi bir şey.
Yani, patika yolda giderken bir anda fm,
fm'in farkı böyle bir şey.
İnanılmaz bir ses yoğunluğu var.
Sadece klasik müzik yayını yapan Trt,
yayın yapıyor orada.
Ben oturuyorum sabahtan akşama kadar
-- hani klasik müziği sevdiğim için
değil ama --
sesin kalitesinden dolayı klasik
müzik dinler hale geldim,
13- 14 yaşındayım.
Sonra, fm radyosunun şöyle bir
özelliği olduğunu öğrendim.
Bir mikrofon alıyorsunuz --
5 wattlık bir vericidir bu --
burdan konuştuğunuz zaman,
radyoyu ayarlıyorsunuz,
kendi sesinizi radyodan duyuyorsunuz,
arkadaşlar.
Konuşuyorsunuz, "Alo, alo",
"Aa, ben konuşuyorum!".
Ama sadece ben dinliyorum,
başka dinleyen yok.
Sadece bana yayın yapıyorum aslında.
Şimdi ben ne yapabilirim,
bunu nasıl yayına çevirebilirim,
13-14 yaşındayım.
Evimiz de bir avlu, etrafı diğer
evlerle çevrili.
Bütün komşuların radyolarını
o frekansa ayarladım.
5 wattlık vericim var,
babamın teybi var,
elimde de bir radyo var,
ben buradan konuşuyorum kendi
sesimi duyuyorum, diyorum ki,
"Ayarladın mı İskender?"
"Ayarladım."
"Ayarladın mı Fatih?"
Fatih, İskender, üç dört beş
kişi ayarladılar
ve ben 5 kişiye, 14 yaşında,
daha özel radyolar yokken ortada,
yayın yapmaya başladım.
Burdan konuşuyorum, teypten
şarkıyı çalıp dinletiyorum.
Konuşuyorum, "Evet şimdi,
size çok güzel bir şarkı çalacağım."
Kim dinliyor?
5 kişi dinliyor.
Bir kere, daha sonra, şunu farkettim
hayatımda, geriye doğru baktığımda.
Ortaca Fm'de çalışıyorum, Muğla, Ortaca.
15000 nüfusu olan bir radyo, arkadaşlar.
Sanki beni dünya dinliyormuş gibi
ciddiye alıyorum.
Size en önemli tavsiyelerimden
bir tanesi şu:
Her ne yapıyorsak yapalım,
o an, o işi ciddiye alalım.
Bizim mesela şirkette çaycı ablamız var,
Neşe abla.
O kadar severek yapıyor ki o çayları,
diyorum ki, senden diyorum acaba
senin diyorum tek yurmuta ikizi
üç tane dört tane mi var acaba,
şirketin her yerinde görüyorum böyle
ve severek yapıyor.
Bizim patron bir gün bana geldi,
geçerken uğradı, Ferit Şahenk.
Çay söyledik, ben çaycı ablayla
Ferit Bey'i tanıştırmak zorunda kaldım.
Dedim ki,
"Patron, bu abla var ya müthiş."
ve Ferit Bey, onunla konuştu.
O, Ferit Bey'in kapsama
alanına girmiş oldu.
Dolasıyla, büyük hedeflere, küçük
adımlarla gidiyoruz, arkadaşlar.
Kimse uçarak gitmiyor.
Dolaysıyla, ne yapacağız?
Bütün adımlarımız çok değerli.
Bir de cüret etme olayı var.
Askerdeyim, Denizli'de,
sıcaktan kavruluyor.
Bir dakika bir yere arazi olabilmek için
-- bakın, bunlar abartılı hikayeler değil,
net yaşanmış hikayeler --
bir dakika bir yere arazi olabilmek için
deliriyorum, ne yapayım?
Bir komutan çıktı karşımıza dedi ki,
"Aranızda müzisyen var mı?"
Aranızda müzisyen var mı,
Allaahh...
Benim elim gayri ihtiyari, baktım havada.
Ben kendi kendime diyorum ki,
ben müzisyen değilim ki ya,
bu elim benim niye havada?
Çağırdı, dedi, "Ne çalıyorsun?".
Dedim, "Bateri çalıyorum."
Dilim konuşuyor ama hâkim
olamıyorum kendime,
gerçekten yani bateri çalıyorum.
Ben burdan bir dakika bir kurtulayım yani,
bir dakika böyle bir yerde
arazi olayım hedefindeyim.
Aa, adam sevindi, komutan.
Bateri çalan birini bulduk.
Bateriye ihtiyaç var,
bateriste ihtiyaç var.
Şimdi, yolda gidiyorum, saz çalanlar,
şarkı söyleyenler
-- şarkı söyleyenleri almıyorlar çünkü
herkes şarkı söylüyor. --
Şimdi, ben burda desem ki
aranızda müzisyen var mı desem.
Aranızda müzisyen var mı,
müziyen var mı, müzisyen?
Peki, ama dürüst olun.
Aranızda şarkı söyleyen var mı?
Lütfen biraz dürüst olun, şu ellerin
hepsini havada göreyim,
şarkı söyleyenleri,
banyoda, mutfakta, yolda giderken.
Evet, herkes şarkıcı.
Dolayısyla, şarkıcı olmanın
bir anlamı yok.
Müzisyen olmak çok önemli.
Neyse, yolda gidiyorum, diyorum ki,
Allah'ım, ne olur
-- şuurumu kaybetmişim herhalde --
bana bateri çalmayı öğret.
(Kahkahalar)
Ama inanın böyle, yolda gidiyorum,
ben diyorum bu bateriyi,
şimdi şeyi elime almadan
-- o sopalara ne diyorlar?
Baget, baget, baget değil mi?
Adını bile bilmiyorum --
Şimdi onları elime almadan,
ben bunu çalıyor muyum,
çalmıyor muyum bilmiyorum,
belki çalacağım.
(Kahkahalar)
Ben dua ederek gidiyorum.
Şimdi, sıraya girdik bekliyoruz,
herkes sırayla çağrıldı:
"Evet, baterist, davulcu!".
Evet, koştum ben, ortada bir havuz var,
oturdum baterinin önüne,
şöyle elime aldım,
-- ciddi söylüyorum bak,
inanın abartı yok --
dua etmeye başladım.
Allah'ım, hadi.
(Kahkahalar)
Daha Matrix filmi yok.
Hani, yükleme de yok.
Hani filmden de esinlenmedim.
Hadi yükle diyorum, hadi çalayım şunu.
"Çal, evladım."
Tak, tak, tuk, tuk, dan...
Ama ben de değişik çalıyorum, çünkü
bir çaldığımı bir daha çalamıyorum.
(Kahkahalar)
Bu da ayrı bir şey, parmak izi
gibi, farklı farklı.
Yani 100 defa çalsam hep farklı çalacağım,
benzeri yok.
"Çalsana."
"Ee, çalıyorum."
Ya şunu demiyorum,
ben çalamıyorum demiyorum,
böyle garip bir durum var.
Neyse, adama baktım tabi,
giderken ben inceledim.
Bu, iyi döver mi, küfür mü eder?
Bir de bando subayı, kibar.
Dedim bundan bir şey olmaz,
hesabını yaptım aslında.
15 gün arazi oldum,
çok işime yaradı.
Şimdi, başka bir -- bu bir cürettir --
başka bir cüretim var.
İstanbul'a geldim, radyolara
girmek istiyorum.
Ama radyo müdürünü bulamıyorum.
Yani bir demo göndermişim,
demoyu beğenmiş, müdür beğenmiş.
Beğendi haberi geldi, ben Marmaris'te
Akdeniz Fm'de işi gücü bıraktım geldim.
Beğendi ya, kırmızı halılar falan
herhalde bekliyorum,
ama müdür yok ortada.
Günlerce, daha derinlemesine
anlatmak isterim.
Ama gerçekten çok ızdırap dolu
günler yaşıyorum.
Mehmet'in Gezegeni olarak
gelmişim İstanbul'a,
ama muhatap yok ortada.
En sonunda kapıdaki güvenlik
bana acıdı, dedi ki,
bak şu var ya, şu gelen adam,
o radyoların müdürü.
İkitelli'de Star binası,
adamın karşısına çıktım.
Harun adı, dedim Harun Bey
-- titriyorum ama zangır zangır böyle --
"Harun Bey?"
"Evet"
-- donmuşum böyle sanki uzaylı görmüş gibi
radyoların müdürü, karşımda --
Ben, dedim Mehmet Gezegen.
Mehmet'in Gezegeni programını yaptım.
Aa, dedi, "O sen misin?" dedi.
Aa, tanıdı beni.
İnanılmaz, tanımış olması hoşuma gitti.
Dedim: "Geldim."
Dedi: "Ben sana gel demedim ki."
"Beğenmişsiniz."
"Beğendim."
"Geldim."
"Beğendim ama gel demedim."
Ee ben hayatımı bıraktım geldim.
Ne güzel Marmaris'te Akdeniz Fm'de,
muhteşem programlar yapıyorum,
hayranlarım var, hayatım var,
herşey çok güzel,
Mehmet'in Gezegeni orada devam ediyor,
gelmişim ben buraya,
sen beğendim dediğin için geldim.
Dedi ki, ben hani gel demedim.
Elimde olmadan adımın kolunu tutmuşum,
aynı davulda olduğu gibi.
Ben hatırlamıyorum o hareketi.
Şu hareketi yapmışım:
Bu benim için ölüm kalım meselesi.
Şimdi, aradan yıllar geçti,
Harun Beyle biz bir araya geldik.
Harun Bey tabi gururla, "Mehmet Gezegen'i
ben aldım, benim eserim."
Harun Bey dedi ki, "Mehmet, ben o gün
senden çok korktum."
(Kahkahalar)
Adam biraz tırsık.
Bu, reklam işleri falan yapıyor,
çok böyle sokak şeyi yok.
"Ben sana bir şey yapacağım
demedim ki."
"Ama ölüm kalım meselesi."
"Ben kendimi öldüreceğim" dedim.
(Kahkahalar)
Yani korkmuş, korktuğu için,
beni işe aldı.
Şimdi, buradan şuraya geleceğim.
İki tane cüret var ortada,
cüretkârlık yani, iki tane atak.
Birincisi, davul çalacağım
diyen bir adam var,
aslında davulla mavulla ilgisi olmayan.
İkincisi, ben bu radyo işini çok iyi
biliyorum deyip
adamın kolunu tutan bir adam var.
Eğer davuldaki cesareti,
iş dünyasında ben yapsaydım,
iş dünyasında hayatım kâbusa dönerdi.
"Geç, çal, hadi bakalım."
"Çalamıyorum."
Bitti, hayatınız bitti.
Öncelikle arkadaşlar, şunu çok iyi
anlamak zorundayız.
Bizden ne olur?
Yani bizden ne olur?
Ben neyi iyi yapabilirim?
Kendinize karşı Allah aşkına dürüst olun.
Senden ne olacağını bilmeden
eğer atak yaparsan,
askerdeki gibi kurtulamazsın.
Dolayısıyla, ben o gün,
o radyo programını yaparım,
sizi de mahçup etmem dedim,
yayına başladım.
Ben İstanbul'a gelmişim,
hayalim Süper Fm.
Kral Fm yok dünyamda, pop çalıyorum.
Beni aldılar City Fm'e koydular, City Fm.
Süper Fm'in çakması.
Ben dedim ki, ne olacak canım,
İstanbul'a hitap ediyorum.
City Fm'de de olsa, 15 bin nüfustan,
50 bin nüfustan,
Marmaris yazın 500 bine çıkıyor,
İstanbul işte 10 milyon nüfus,
nüfus hesabı yapıyorum yani,
işte kaç nüfus.
Çünkü tek hedefim var,
"Merhaba Türkiye" demek.
Radyoculuktaki tek hayalim bu.
Ulusal bir radyodan Türkiye'ye seslenmek.
City Fm'e gittim arkadaşlar,
ben kendimi parçalamışım
oraya gelene kadar,
kapıdaki güvenlik geliyor yayın yapıyor.
Temizlikçi geliyor yayın yapıyor.
Bildiğiniz yolgeçen hanı, gelen yayın
yapıyor, giden yayın yapıyor.
Dedim ki, ben bunun için mi bu kadar
mücadele verdim, bu ne, dedim.
Gözü şeye diktim, Süper Fm'e.
Ben bu Süper Fm'e nasıl geçebilirim.
Kadir Çöpdemirler falan o zaman
yıkıyor ortalığı.
Süper Fm'de, bir arkadaşımız
küçük bir hata yaptı,
Cem Uzan'ın karısının isteğini
çalmadı diye
güvenlik zoruyla dışarı atıldı.
Dedim ki, ben buradan uzak durayım,
burası tehlikeli, bu Süper Fm.
Süper Fm, Cem Uzan'ın çok net
dinlediği bir radyo.
Baktım, yan tarafta Kral Fm var,
o da benim gibi terk edilmiş sanki.
Halkın sahip çıktığı,
bütün Türkiye'nin dinlediği
ama beyaz yakalıların farkında
olmadığı bir radyo.
Cem Uzan'ın öyle bir radyosu var ama,
var mı yok mu haberi yok.
Baktım, Kral Fm, bildiğiniz
minibüs gibi bir şey.
İçerde böyle mektuplar, acayip bir şey,
yani inanılmaz bir havası var.
Şimdi, ben Kral Fm'e diktim gözü ama
Kral Fm'de çalışan arkadaşlar
beni istemiyorlar.
Beni çok sosyete buluyorlar, oraya göre.
Napayım, napayım, napayım?
Dedim ki, "Arkadaşlar,ben her birinizin
izin gününde yayın yapayım.
Bakın, sizin yayın saatlerinize
dokunmuyorum.
Sen izinliyken ben senin yerine yapayım,
sen izinliyken, sen izinliyken,
sen izinliyken."
Bunların izin günlerini
bir ele geçirdim şöyle.
Bu arada, bütün saatlerde ben varım.
(Kahkahalar)
Bir sabah duyuyorlar, bir akşam
duyuyorlar, bir gece duyuyorlar.
Ara ara Süper Fm'e gidiyorum,
orada da yayın yapıyorum.
Boş olan heryeri dolduruyorum yani.
City Fm, Süper Fm, Kral Fm,
sabah akşam yayın yapıyorum,
delirmiş gibi.
Sonra baktım, sabah yayınını
kimse istemiyor.
Sabah saat 6'da kalkacaksın,
yola çıkacaksın,
dedim ki, ben buradayım.
(Kahkahalar)
Sabah yayınını aldım, saat 7'den 12'ye
kadar yayın yapıyorum.
Bu, 5 sene falan sürdü.
Arkadaşlar,
İstanbul Üniveristesi araştırma yapıyor,
ilk araştırma sonuçları geldi,
Mehmet'in Gezegeni üçüncü sırada.
Daha maaş almıyorum,
(Kahkahalar)
kadrolu değilim.
İkinci araştırma geldi,
Mehmet'in Gezegeni birinci sırada.
Mehmet'in Gezegeni,
o Kaybedenler Kulübü filmi var ya,
oradaki o birinci benim aslında,
onun üstünü kapatmışlar.
(Alkışlar)
Bu arada,
eğer böyle programlar,
böyle filmler yapıyorsanız,
gerçekleri şey yapmayın,
Kaybedenler Kulübü hiçbir zaman
-- bu bir dedikodu gibi algılanmasın --
hiçbir reyting araştırmasında
birinci sırada olmadı.
Birinci olanları söylüyorum size,
benim dönemimde,
Geveze,
Beyaz,
benimle birlikte çalışan sevgili Ata.
Anlatabiliyor muyum? Orada, o filmde
böyle bir yanıltmaca var,
bunu açık bir şekilde söylüyorum.
Ee o birinci, "Evet sonunda
birinci olduk."
Olamadınız siz birinci.
İnsanları bu konuda yanıltmayın.
Şimdi, biraz önce,
içeride çok değerli arkadaşımızla
bir konuşma yaparken,
hemen ben notumu aldım.
Ben sürekli açım bu konuda.
Bilgi konusunda açım.
Şunu söyleyeceğim,
en değerli fikirler,
en kıymetli fikirler,
altın değerindeki öneriler,
size en küçümsediklerinizden gelir.
Kimseyi hayatta küçümsemeyin,
çünkü evren size mesajı gönderiyor
-- evren size ne yapacak,
mektup mu gönderecek? --
Evrenden mesaj geliyor, kimle gönderecek?
Çaycı ablayla gönderecek,
kapıdaki güvenlikle gönderecek,
yeni tanıştığınız bir arkadaşınızla
gönderecek,
evrenin dili olacak.
Dolayısıyla, en kıymetli,
en değerli fikirler,
en önemsemediklerinizle size gelir.
Şimdi, biz kendi hayatımıza baktığımızda,
babalarımız kozaydı.
Bizim yaşımız, bizim dönemimiz tırtıl,
sizler kelebeksiniz.
Tırtıldan kelebeğe dönüşenlersiniz.
Ya tırtıl olarak öleceksiniz
-- Allah korusun --
ya da kelebek olup uçacaksınız.
Bunu neden söylüyorum,
gazetelerin son sayfalarında,
şöyle bir haberler okuruz hep.
Dünyaya göktaşı geliyor, dünyada
hayat bitecek.
Güneşin ömrü bitiyor, hayat bitiyor.
Şu oluyor, bu oluyor,
ozon tabakası deliniyor,
altta da küçücük bir yazı var:
1 milyon yıl sonra,
5 milyon yıl sonra,
1 milyar yıl sonra.
Ne olacak, biz mi yaşayacağız,
1 milyon yıl sonra hayat mı kalacak,
diyoruz kendi kendimize
veya 1 milyar yıl sonra.
Kıyamet kapıda, dijital kıyamet,
teknolojik kıyamet.
302 otobüsler vardı biliyor musunuz?
Hatırlayanlar var mı 302 otobüsleri?
Kimse yok hatırlayan,
var mı Allah aşkına, 302.
Ya 302 ya, inanamıyorum.
Senin yaşın kaç?
302'yi nerden biliyorsun?
Şimdi, 302, yirmi yıl bu ülkede
hüküm sürdü.
302'si olanlar dedi ki,
"302'im var kardeşim.
Ne olacak, kralım ben."
303 çıktı, kıyamet başladı.
304, 303'ün S'i, 300 bilmem ne,
sürekli değişen otobüs markaları.
Artık, dün Instagram vardı, Twitter vardı,
bugün Periscop var,
yarın başka bir şey olacak.
Çok hızlı ve dinamik olmak zorundayız.
Geç kalmayacağız, teknolojiyi yakından
takip edeceğiz.
Eğer teknolojiyi yakından takip etmezsek,
teknoloji bizim canavarımız olur.
Ben toparlamak istiyorum izin verirseniz.
Katıldığım toplantılarda beni
üzen bir görüntü var,
en son Doğuş Grubu ile bir toplantıdaydım,
orada böyle bir konuşma yaptım,
yöneticilerimizin huzurunda.
Daha önceden konuşan arkadaşlar,
konuşma sonrasında,
"Sorusu olan var mı?" diye sorduklarında,
iki tane el gördüm havada
ve ben kendi konuşmamın
sonunda şöyle kapattım:
Dedim ki, bir hayal kurmak istiyorum
sizlerle beraber.
Çünkü Türkiye'nin şu anda
-- gençlerin en büyük problemi bu --
herkes izlemeyi seviyor,
katılmayı sevmiyor.
Tamam, izleyelim. Yani tribünlerde olalım,
oyunun içine girmeyelim.
Oyunun içine girmek, soruyla başlar.
O toplantıda, Antalya'da
yaptığımız toplantıda dedim ki,
"Bir hayal kurmak istiyorum.
Bu hayalimi burada yaşamak istiyorum.
Sorusu olan var mı dediğimde,
lütfen bütün eller havada olsun" dedim.
"Sorusu olan var mı?" dedim.
İlk kalkan el Ferit Şahenk'in eliydi,
daha sonra bütün salonun tamamı
elini havaya kaldırdı.
Katılım rica ediyorum.
Buraya bir kişinin hayatına
dokunmak için geldim,
bir kişi de benim hayatıma dokunabilir.
Hani böyle bencillik yapmıyorum,
ben bir kişinin hayatına dokunacağım,
ben müthiş bir sihirbazım
noktasında değilim.
Yıllar önce, hayal kuruyordum.
Gözlerimi kapatıp çocukluğuma
gitmek istiyorum tekrar
ve finali böyle yapacağım.
Gözlerimi kapatıp hayal kuruyorum.
Açtığımda, aynı davulda olduğu gibi
hayal ettiğim yerde olmayı
düşünüyordum, çocukken.
Kapatıyorum gözlerimi, açıyorum,
aynı yerdeyim, kapatıyorum.
Daha sonra, bir lamba aldım kendime,
içinden cin çıkan, gerçekten aldım.
Böyle çaktırmadan, kimse yokken
böyle ovuyorum,
içinden bir cin çıksın,
o cin bana desin ki şöyle,
"Dile benden ne dilersen."
Ben de ondan üç tane dilekte bulunacağım,
dileklerim kafamda.
Lambayı ovdum ovdum içinden cin çıkmadı.
(Kahkahalar)
Çıkmadı.
Ve yıllar sonra, bugün geldiğim noktada,
o cinin hiçbir zaman
lambadan çıkmayacağını,
(Kahkahalar)
o cinin aslında benim içimde
olduğunu hissettim.
İçinizdeki cinleri, içinizdeki cinleri
-- her birinizin içinde birer cin var --
o cinleri serbest bırakın.
O cin, şöyle çıksın karşınıza
ve "Dile benden ne dilersen"
diye sorduğunda,
dileklerinizi ona yapın.
(Alkışlar)
Sorusu olan var mı arkadaşlar?
Bütün elleri havada görmek istiyorum,
bu benim hayalim.
Sorusu olan var mı?
Sizi alkışlıyorum.
(Alkışlar)